the boeing 747 it's the jumbo jet that
made long distance travel more
affordable
and was the crown jewel of boac's fleet
a company you may now know as british
airways by the end of the year
boac will have extended its jumbo
services around the world on most of its
key routes
but in 2020 after five decades ba has
decided to bring forward its plans to
retire the 747
as have other airlines like qantas and
virgin atlantic
it's a visible sign of how airlines are
having to quickly transform themselves
to survive the coronavirus pandemic
the industry has been decimated
passenger volumes dropped an
unprecedented 95
in april and the industry is set to lose
84 billion dollars this year alone
a number of airlines around the world
have already gone bust
it's a little bit like the game of
survivor we don't know how long the
downturn is going to last
so to stay in business airlines have to
move quickly
and face make or break choices at a time
of zero visibility
a first critical choice is whether or
not to keep flying
and where to send those planes when
demand is so low
flying too many planes means losing
money but
flying too few means missing out on
passenger demand
and potentially losing market share
getting that balance right
is absolutely crucial how can i stay in
that market
how can i continue to be active but not
fly unnecessary journeys with empty
aircraft for many airlines that's the
great dilemma
airlines in the us are going about it in
very different ways
american has said uh we're gonna
take as many people as we can pack them
into the airplane
reduce our cash losses each day
there are some people who need to travel
there are some people who want to travel
so let's get them let's get them all but
delta
has said it's going to have the number
of planes it's bringing back
leaving its capacity around a quarter of
what it was last year
taking flights out of your schedule does
help you save cash it certainly reduces
your
your daily operating costs um and you
know it's quite simple
if you only have enough passengers for
one or two flights a day you only want
to be fine one or two fights a day
striking the right balance is
particularly difficult
and airlines can't even rely on their
usual forecast data
as few customers are planning travel
ahead of time
they've lost all of their historic data
around booking demand when people book
for what routes
how far in advance how much they're
prepared to pay
that makes another crucial decision
particularly pressing
whether or not to keep their staff if
you're talking about 50
of the world's fleet being grounded at
this moment in time and 50
of the world's um capacity not flying at
this moment in time
you don't need to be a rocket scientist
i mean that probably means 50
of people employed in the aviation
industry are not going to be
required certainly through the winter of
this year while
carriers like cathay pacific and hong
kong have asked their employees to take
unpaid leave
others like emirates have laid off staff
in the u.s
airlines that accepted government money
under the cares act promised not to lay
off or furlough workers until the end of
september
but have looked for other options you
know what they're asking for
from employees and labor is usually
their
their number one or number two cost
they're asking for
forgiveness voluntary leaves working
fewer hours than what's guaranteed in
their contracts
different relief forms like that
american has warned
25 000 of its staff that their jobs are
at risk once funding
expires and united said it's exploring
shedding 36
000 employees nearly half of its u.s
workforce
but furloughing specialized workers can
have long-term consequences
you don't want to furlough a pilot for
just a couple months
and then have to bring them back for a
couple months of training uh
and and you don't want to create
training cycles where you just
jam up uh your facilities and you can't
get the people trained that you
need to get trained there are only so
many hours in the flight simulators
back to those 747. the jumbo's cruising
speed of 625 miles an hour
makes relatively short work of the
atlantic flight huge planes like these
which can sometimes carry more than 500
passengers
have become difficult to fill as few
people are flying around the world
and boeing has said it will stop
producing the 747
all together in 2022 the 747 is an
expensive point to fly
four engines are always more expensive
than two engines
and the reality is the bigger older
planes are the ones that
don't make sense anymore but it's not
just a matter of
cost the retirement of so many 747s
reveals a much deeper change the
aircraft was designed and it has been
used
most recently with quite large
proportions of first and business class
seats
now the one thing that is not coming
back and is certainly not coming back
quickly is corporate demand
delta ceo ed bastian told analysts he
didn't expect corporate flying to ever
recover to its pre-pandemic level
you can often cover the cost of a flight
just filling
the business class seats and then
everything else in coach is profit
but if that's not the case business
travel doesn't come back
then what do you do in just a few months
what had been a steadily growing sector
for decades
has become a huge loss-making business
for airlines
and the choices they make now will
likely change the way we fly for years
to come
do they have the confidence that they're
going to call it correctly you know
do we know what's going to happen in the
future it would be a brave call for any
airline to
to make such a dramatic change of
position in the market so
[Music]
quickly